baker mayfield getting his work in as he
gets ready for year number three year
one great year two
not so great the cleveland browns you
know last year the problem was chris
they allowed the expectations to get out
of control and one of the things that
first year and only year coach freddie
kitchens didn't realize
is i need to do something to reel these
expectations in
yeah ended up not having a horrible
season but it was never going to live up
to expectations unless they got to the
super bowl it was ridiculous
now this year fortunately for the browns
the one good
news item for cleveland the bar is far
lower it's going to be a lot easier to
come out of this season with the
perception and reality that you exceeded
your expectations
definitely i mean yes they're off you
know last year we were all like
are you kidding me odell beckham jr
and kareem hunter on that football team
and we saw the way baker mayfield ended
his rookie year to where we just thought
oh my gosh
the browns are going to be like in super
bowl playoff contention and this is
going to be unbelievable to watch
well that didn't happen you're right and
you know there's something to win in the
nfl as we've talked
about a lot and being battle tested and
understanding how to
handle certain situations of a game
especially in those
last four minutes of the first half and
the end of the game that really
determine
whether you win by two or lose by two
and they were
you know not great in those departments
and of course baker mayfield didn't have
a great year but
but cleveland is one of those teams i
like where you put them in your rankings
because they're again we hit it
yesterday
they're one of those teams i certainly
got a little star next to to go oh they
didn't make the playoffs last year this
would be one of the teams that i would
put in that small group
if you made me put money to go they're
going to be in that conversation this
year and they very likely could be in
the playoffs
yeah we got him at number 18 in the
preseason power rankings and remember
that extra spot in each conference makes
it easier for a team to get to the
postseason makes
more teams than not relevant and alive
deeper into the season
you know the problem last year with the
browns beyond the expectations may have
been that freddy kitchens
just wasn't suited for the job and i say
may have been
in an effort to be polite and kind to
freddie kitchens it became obvious he
was over his skis as i said last year
he's so far over his skis he doesn't
even know he has skis on at this point
and remember when bob wiley the guy who
became an unlikely star of hard knocks
two years ago because of that giant
belly that would have been unison with
his
commands he got he got let go when
freddie kitchens became the head coach
so it's easy to say oh he's just
disgruntled but he did a radio interview
last year and he said look
it wasn't for any kitchens that was
getting the most out of baker mayfield
in 2018 it was ken zampesey the
quarterbacks coach he was doing all that
stuff
zampese also got the shoe so
in hindsight bob wiley kind of looked
like he was onto something because
whoever was there
wasn't able to get the same thing out of
mayfield that we saw
in 2018 so that leads into this fill in
the blank thing we're going to do chris
baker mayfield's performance thus far in
his career 2018 and 2019 taken together
has been what a roller coaster
you know an up and down affair i mean
rookie year was
phenomenal i mean it was he was in the
voting with saquon barkley
to you know where we were going man i
don't know who's going to win you know
we saw plays and we saw a guy that just
doesn't
really blink in in the face of pressure
or anything like that and then we got
into the second year
and not to say that he was blinking in
the face of pressure but i think he was
blinking a little bit in the face of
expectations and oh man
i gotta get odell beckham jr the ball
and i'm supposed to be
you know taking that next step as a star
and yeah
his game faltered a little bit you know
we've talked about some of the technique
issues he had and
just some of the careless decisions he
made and that led to a year last year
that was a little all over the place
added to the fact again i don't want to
blame baker mayfield
to all the things you said about last
year in cleveland with freddie kitchens
and
sometimes the style in which they
approached the football game and the way
they wanted to play it i didn't think
always made sense
you know that that would be the thing it
wasn't a cohesive game plan altogether
it was kind of like
i got these weapons and we're just going
to go out there and let it fly and you
want to go well wait you can't pass
protect
your quarterback's a little off right
now odell beckham jr is not wholly
healthy
jarvis landry's not totally healthy how
about we play through the run game the
o-line's a really good running blocking
team
you know there was too many games where
they tried to be the greatest show on
turf where i wanted to go
that's not what you are this year just
play to your strength and that's where
kevin stefanski i think is going to
really come in handy for this team
chris the word i'm going to use for
baker mayfield so far is disappointing
he came in as the number one overall
pick in the draft and he
really created that expectation that he
was going to quickly join
the ranks of franchise quarterbacks like
patrick mahomes
did right like a lamar jackson has done
and that follow-up from mayfield and i
think part of it was
you know cleveland was so desperate for
someone they could rally around
like lebron james sure they wanted that
superstar
they wanted that guy and then they got
oto beckham jr as well i don't think
anybody knew
what to do with two of them but i feel
like baker mayfield
just didn't embrace that
that moment that opportunity that chance
to be the franchise quarterback we
talked when
we did the countdown of your quarterback
rankings about those technical issues
the mechanical flaws that got into his
game last year
if you're going to be one of the
high-end franchise quarterbacks even if
you're not getting the right coaching
you're doing that yourself you're
getting the coaching away from your own
coach and you've got tom house
working on your mechanics in the
offseason you're not doing all these
commercials that baker mayfield did
last year you're not cashing in before
you've won anything and i don't mean
this to be a criticism of baker mayfield
i just think maybe he could let the cart
get a little too far in front of the
horse last year
and now the question is can he get
things realigned and humble himself a
little bit
take a lower profile and go back to the
lab and understand what it truly means
to be a franchise quarterback
it's not just having one good season
it's really committing yourself
every day of the year to being exactly
what you need to be for those 16 games
in the regular season well
i think he's willing to do that listen
you make some points there that i agree
with you know disappointing i think
that's a little strong
i do he isn't you know he's given them
hope
he is a playmaker and a guy that has
talent to be a top 10 quarterback game
changing type
guy you know i'm not going to say
patrick mahomes we know that's a that's
a special
rare class there but you know okay the
where i will agree with you a little bit
is
yeah maybe he got you know you know a
little too big for his britches right
where
okay great first year i won the heisman
and you're right the commercial thing
and maybe he lost a little bit of that
i'm gonna just you know sneak under the
radar and grind and work
and lead my football team so i
understand that aspect but
i i don't i don't at least look at it as
a disappointment baker mayfield just so
you know that out there that was
that was mike florio no no no no you
know what you're joking but you're not
joking
and one of the things he's got to mature
past is this idea of having these little
feuds and settling scores
and you know the tony grossi stuff if
you want to be a franchise quarterback
baker you got to set that bag down let
it motivate you internally but you can't
act that way that's just
it's not going to fly patrick mahomes
doesn't act that way lamar
jackson doesn't act that way tyler
murray's not going to act that way
if you want to be a true franchise
quarterback you got to get past
that that stick up your butt pardon me
attitude
you know let it fuel you inside but
don't let that bubble up because it's
not going to win you fans
when things go sideways if everything's
fine people are just going to say well
that's just baker being baker
the moment you stumble people are going
to say yeah that guy's kind of a jerk
anyway well be more in
you know what do i want we want to say
mahomes does it but he's got a good way
of doing it where it doesn't seem like
it's angering him and he's being rude to
people in the process and that's where
probably baker mayfield came off
a little the wrong way there you know
but this off season
we haven't heard much from baker and
it's it sounds like it's been all work
and we heard you know i saw an article
the other day kevin stefanski was down
in austin texas
working with them i think there's a
highly motivated guy who's going to be
back on his a game this year and fix up
fix some of the issues and of course
they got a supporting cast and i think a
guy in kevin stefanski who
is a good offensive coordinator and
really
he wants to run what he did in minnesota
and i go okay yeah they did some good
things in minnesota
and believe it or not the browns are set
up to run that minnesota offense better
than minnesota
they're better across the board two
receivers better in cleveland
tight ends better in cleveland offensive
line
better in cleveland running backs oh
it's close
it's really close i don't know where i'd
go there and then i do think baker
mayfield is capable of more specialness
you know than a kirk cousins he's not
kirk cousins yet
but he has the ability to certainly make
more plays and do more off schedule that
way
and that's where i get pumped up for
cleveland and kevin stefanski
and joe woods the d coordinator as well
with the defense we haven't even talked
about yet that's
got some freaky dudes on that side too
cleveland's roster
is legit it is legit and if they're not
in that like last two weeks
playoffs uh conversation i will be
disappointed because there is no excuse
they
they got it all here the all-important
dividing line between the quarterback
who can run the play that's called in
the quarterback who can
improvise you know run the play that
isn't called cousins
fortunately or unfortunately rather
sorry kirk
can only run the play that's called
mayfield can do it
uh beyond that uh real quickly best case
worst case best case i i'm gonna go out
i mean again this is
best case i think they're capable of
winning the division i do
now i'm not gonna sit here and tell you
i bet money but would i sit here with
that team and that roster and be shocked
if they were sitting there at 11 and
five or 12 and 4
and won the division i can't say that i
would with that superstar power and what
they've done this off season in the
draft and free agency
worst case man i i can't
imagine it the absolute worst would be
six and ten i mean the absolutely
intense
right thing i was thinking the exact
same thing six and ten
it kind of reminds me the falcons we
talked about the falcons yesterday
everybody's talking buccaneers saints
the falcons could swing up on the
outside
in the afc north it's raven steelers
raven steelers raven steelers they're
all here
swing up on the outside and and now look
the bengals who knows what they're going
to do but i think those three teams off
those three teams
cleveland pittsburgh baltimore one of
those three is going to win the division
that's really narrowing it down
but i think the browns could sneak up on
the two teams that we assume will be
battling
for the top of the division hi i'm mike
tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports